so I've evolved Way Beyond Lamborghinis
and chicks right but masculinity as a
whole is a very complicated tapestry you
need to have the emotionality you need
to have the times you feel like crying
and you don't you need to have the times
you can be aggressive you have the times
that you can be violent to protect your
family it's very complicated and you
can't teach that especially to the Young
Generation in in in spite of the
constant propaganda they have coming in
their ears very easily so I break it
down to a very core message and the core
message is that I have Financial Freedom
so it's hard to tell me what to do and I
have sexual access because I'm respected
by women and I have a good Network
because I'm respected by men I break it
down to those core things